what a thought trolls would be the ones
to change the world I don't know how
many people have been following anything
like this cuz like honestly I get it if
a lot of folks have just stopped
following movie news cuz there's almost
no news because production has been shut
down pretty much across the board it'll
start picking up again but anyways it's
been a slow news for a lot of movie
related sites however I still go and I
still check things and I have been
following some wrinkles that I've been
spawned out of the release of trolls
world tour now the thing is what I'm
about to talk about I'm gonna be usually
using trolls world tour basically is the
catalyst for everything going on and a
leaping off point to talk about this
this situation was not created by this
movie but it may well become a tipping
point or a milestone in things changing
in a big way so trolls world tour was
originally supposed to come out
theatrically however we all know what
happened we don't need to dwell on it
it's still ongoing all that happened in
movie theaters were pretty much all
closed down now a lot of major film
releases were simply put off and delayed
all sorts of stuff got pushed back
months or even a year
but neo to be released in theaters at a
later date trolls did something
different what Universal decide to do
with trolls was to skip theatrical go
direct to video on-demand at a twenty
dollar price point so that was their
tactic basically it's saying we're not
gonna delay we we want to release this
in this format now doing that in and of
itself
nobody was raising a massive sting buck
and I say nobody I mean other companies
will sort of we'll fill in some gaps as
we go because at the time was like look
it's extraordinary circumstances
you're choosing to do this thing that is
outside the normal way that this would
normally be done okay but then that
would that went so well that release and
even though there's now like some
disagreement as to whether or not the
film is actually profitable but I mean
Hollywood accounting who knows what
films are profitable and by what margin
but in any case the simple fact is
Studios like Universal keep a much
higher percentage of the take on video
on-demand releases than they do
theatrical it varies on a film by film
basis as does basically anything but
rule of thumb studios get about 50% of
the take on a theatrical release
video-on-demand likely what they do the
trolls they get about 80 now again exact
numbers will vary but there is no
question that the studio gets a higher
percentage of video in the on-demand and
with that release having been so
successful Universal basically made the
mistake of opening their mouths and
saying you know in the future we'll
probably look at alternating between
video and demand releasing theatrical or
maybe a little short in the window from
once the other we're gonna look into it
this went well for us well that set off
a bit of a domino effect because after
that I think it was AMC and then it was
Regal or it might have been the other
way around but at this point the two
biggest theatrical chains in the country
have said if you do this we will not
exhibit films released by you we will
not show Universal films in our theaters
so battle lines are getting drawn here
now there is context for this this isn't
coming out of nowhere because the
theatrical experience is kind of I don't
want to say it's been in danger but it's
been in an uncertain place or at least
hasn't had an Una's had an uncertain
future for a little while and that's
largely because of streaming now the
thing is up to this point for the most
part when it comes to the battle between
theaters and streaming services
most major film studios if they had
picked aside were leaning in favor of
the theatrical model but this was kind
of the first time that a major studio
vocalized saying yeah maybe we'll go the
other direction so in some ways this was
seen as this is probably part of what
prompted such a harsh reaction from the
theater chains because it probably felt
to them a little bit like a stab in the
back when they're in a very vulnerable
position because pretty much all their
entire businesses are shut down right
now hey everybody its Nathaniel while
editing so there was something I meant
to talk about but didn't I'm gonna add
him real quick there's an additional
wrinkle in all of this and that is the
stars involved some standard contracts
particularly for things like animation
have the residuals for the actors
largely dependent on the theatrical run
so in the case of trolls World Tour Anna
Kendrick and Justin Timberlake are now
not going to see the returns they would
have expected for the size of the
opening the film had on digital and
there was even talk of lawsuits being
filed because of that so the question
now becomes what's gonna happen going
forward with theatrical distribution
because things are heating up and the
longer this goes on in more areas the
harder is going to be now first off just
the fact that these places are closed
makes everything harder because you know
they're not bringing in business because
they can't sell tickets and cram people
into theaters but they've still got you
know taxes on their property they still
have some degree of employees on the
payroll even if it's only the
bookkeepers at the head office they
still have expenses that can that need
to be paid but they're not bringing in
any revenue now that is certainly not a
situation unique to movie theaters right
now that is a problem that a lot of
businesses are going through right now
so don't by any means think I mean I boo
the poor theater chain I was like Nook
everybody everybody's getting hit by
this but this is just the narrow window
that
that I'm talking about today so the
question is what is this going to look
like going forward as these places start
to open up again as they are able to
exhibit again and and honestly initially
probably not in the numbers that they're
used to because with the way a lot of
states are looking at reopening in a
sort of rolling fashion what we're
probably looking at is theaters will be
allowed to open but only be able to sell
at like maybe a third capacity so that
there's two empty seats between each
occupied seats to maintain proper social
distancing something of that nature you
know stagger people out and where they
can sit but to do that you can't sell as
many tickets so there's a potential for
a continual bleed of funds and it's and
if something like that happens then even
as movie theaters start to reopen it's
in the interest of the studios to hold
off their major releases until they can
have full theaters again until that's
allowable and safe so my first instinct
is that what should maybe happen and
what I say should I don't mean like this
is what I want I love going to movie
theaters but what it feels like in many
ways the trajectory of where things are
going is a little bit like the music
industry because when digital came
around the music industry initially
fought it tooth and nail eventually
started making use of it and it did okay
by them as you know the record labels
and artists who were able to work the
new system but actual stores music
stores record stores they are what went
under now music stores aren't gone
completely but they're now a specialty
sort of thing they're you know you go to
places to buy vinyl or vintage posters
or they are niche they're single
location they're not these big massive
chains anymore and I think that in a
sort of naturally progressing
of where things are headed in terms of
digital and everything else what would
make sense is if theaters just became a
little bit more of a niche product and
because there's always gonna be people
who want a theatrical expand I want a
theatrical experience but there's a lot
of things to consider beyond just
whether or not you feel like being
crammed into the movie theater for this
especially with something like trolls to
you that's a family film so if you're
gonna look at taking the family you know
just say as numbers to parents to kids
that means you're paying ten to fifteen
dollars per person just to get them in
the door then you gotta buy snacks you
are looking at probably upwards of a
hundred dollars to take you know at all
said and done to take for people to see
trolls or you can spend 20 bucks and see
it at home you can't really blame anyone
who's looking at it with that kind of
metric here's where things break down
though for a comparison to something
like music stores the value of the
theatrical experience is in large part
right now it is weighted heavily in
favor of this is where you see it first
and if there are fewer theaters if it
starts to become more of a niche thing
then studios are going to lose their
incentive to have the window that
currently exists between when the films
go to the theaters and when they become
available digitally and that window is
basically what most the theaters
especially the big theater chains live
and die on and there have been massive
repeated negotiations between the
theater chains and the studios about
that window because obviously the
studio's want to narrow it and the
chains want it for as long as possible
so they they basically have the
exclusive first-run on these things
now the theater chains do have power in
this because they the doing well
theatrically is huge and it's trolls
world tour is an odd thing because we're
in a very unusual situation right now
we're in uncharted territory but broadly
speaking most things that do really well
digitally also did quite well
theatrically not always there are
exceptions but a strong theatrical run
is usually going to get you a decent
digital run it's not too often that
something bombs in the theater and then
doesn't and then does really well
digitally and there's a feeling and a
sense that the strong theatrical push is
basically that's your marketing end of
it and then when it gets released on
digital if you were to only do that and
to skip the marketing you're gonna get
lost in the shuffle because the
visibility of a theatrical run is part
of what gets it gets people aware of it
in a way that doesn't really happen in
the digital space because the digital
space is honestly a lot more crowded the
number of Studios that can afford to do
a wide release of a theatrical film now
that Disney bought Fox there aren't that
many left firm major studios it's Warner
Brothers Universal paramount Disney Sony
that's pretty much it at this point
MGM is still around but like in a weird
financial quagmire most of us of the
what were the many ones have been
swallowed up by parent companies things
like new line in Miramax and Fox got
bought out there aren't that many
companies that can actually do that size
of a roll out anymore which even though
there are a tons of theaters released
there aren't that many Studios releasing
them because not that many can afford to
do the theatrical run digital space
there is a lot more competition not just
from other movies but from literally
anything that you can stream to your
television every TV show every video
game you know put
you two bikes whatever you can put on
your screen the studio's releasing
movies have to compete with whereas they
put it in a theater what's in a theater
besides movies so what's gonna happen
going forward I don't know for certain
but I can tell you it's gonna get ugly
because some of these studios definitely
I don't know what the theatrical changes
could possibly do about it but some of
these studios definitely are going to be
putting in contingency plans for if and
when something like this ever happens
again because pretty much every industry
was blindsided by the scope and scale of
what has happened however if they're
smart at all then they are at least
planning for well what if it happens
again and it doesn't and depending on
what that plan looks like it's not that
big a leap where if you start crunching
numbers and you start to realize that
your contingency plan might actually be
more profitable than your current first
plan and then things start to shift I
think that is distinctly possible it's
gonna be tough and another part of the
reason why in my mind I you know having
smaller niche theaters I'm totally down
with theirs I that's what's in my town
is small single location theaters not
chains so I know that they they do exist
out there still but there aren't many
left and I don't know how many of those
are gonna be able to come back after
this so that's another place where my
earlier comparison that the music
industry potentially breaks down which
is that the chains right now are the
vast majority of what's left and if they
start to go down there's not going to be
a ton of just theaters left at all and
then
comes back to what I said when there
aren't that many it's not worth it to
the studios anymore to have that window
maybe it's still worth doing the
theatrical run but having that gap that
window and then you shorten the window
and people go I could go to the theater
or I could wait a month and get it
digital and some people will some people
always will some people will always want
the theatrical experience some people
will always want their music on vinyl
some people will always want to buy a
physical copy of a video game
but those people are not sufficient to
sustain the model that exists right now
there weren't enough of those people to
sustain music stores in the face of
digital we're seeing over time how
physical release of video games a lot of
those things plays like Game Stop are
struggling with everything going on
because and have been for a while there
are still people who want that product
but because the demand from investors
and company owners and CEOs is continual
growth being a niche service that
doesn't get you that I really do feel
like things are gonna shake up a lot in
the next year for the theatrical
releases and that may trickle down to an
effect on film production we may start
to see fewer or less expensive films
because if the theatrical run gets
dinged because either because of these
battle lines being drawn or because
there's fewer places to exhibit them
that's a chunk of the expected revenue
that's gone and studios may not have the
money to do as many hugely budgeted
films anymore maybe it trickles down
that way it's hard to know but this this
feels like the start of whatever's gonna
change it feels like it's starting now
and I do honestly think that trolls
world tour is gonna get pointed out as
like that
that was the point where the new
direction was chosen well see that was
random and rambley but I I needed to
needed to get my thoughts out on it so
the at Racal exhibition of films
thoughts whatever they are drop
something on down into comments let's
talk about it I also did a review of
trolls world tour if you care at all
that's up on my secondary channel break
room of geeks and the usual stuff like
subscribe patreon etc so there's all
that stuff to do but you don't have to
cuz end of the day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]